I just find insecurity so boring
I don't know if it's because I did work on myself
and learn to love myself better
or if it's cause I'm a Leo
or it's because I'm burnt up from capitalism
but like the world is on fire
no one can afford to do anything
we have two eight year old men running for president
people can't afford groceries
and you want me to care that I'm fat
you want me to give a heck about my double chin
that that's what I should be worried about
you know maybe Jaden Smith was right
we should be worried about the political and economic state of the world
who has the time to be insecure
we have such little time to ourselves
and you want me to spend that time hating myself
like hang out with your friend
go make out with someone
read a book literally
doing anything is a better use of your time than sitting around
looking in the mirror and hating the thing that you're seeing
and no offense
I'm tired of talking about it
I'm so tired about hearing about everyone's insecurities
you have one body
you have one life
don't waste it hating yourself
it's exhausting
and if that really is the thing that you wanna spend your time doing
fine do it
but don't make it everyone else's problem
a and B for those of us who don't care
don't try and make us care
I'm happy with myself
why would I bother anyone